I don't want to spend a huge amount of
time on this but I do want to mention
that Vice President Joe Biden told a
small group of reporters yesterday that
he is going in the direction of running
for president in the year 2020 saying
quote yeah I am I am going to run in
2020 then he was asked well what are you
going to run for and he said for
president and also you know what the
hell man anyway also adding I'm not
committing not to run I'm not committed
to anything I learned a long time ago
fate has a strange way of intervening
and we know that that at least may be a
reference to calls for Joe Biden to run
for president this year and the horrible
and sad passing of his son Beau Biden
due to brain cancer and that may be a
reference that that Joe Biden was making
interestingly Joe Biden would be 77
years old on election day in 2020 and I
think that because Joe Biden is such an
excellent debater those debates would be
brutal for Donald Trump but age is a
factor and we've talked about the need
for the Democratic Party to go younger
rather than older so while I absolutely
love Joe Biden fantastic debater made
mincemeat of Paul Ryan during the 2012
vice presidential debate I don't know
that Joe Biden is the path forward for
the Democratic Party well I think age is
becoming less and less of a factor as
lifespans continue to increase but I
think it's important too that in 2020 we
put up someone with a strong personality
because I think that's the only way
you're gonna be able to take someone
down like Trump I agree with you and
taking out an incumbent president is
going to be particularly difficult I
think for someone who's nearly 80 years
old and first ran for president in 1988
you need hi-hi-hi energy and I love Joe
Biden's energy and I think he's awesome
again this is not a critique of Joe
Biden whatsoever I think there's a
strong case to be made that 2016 is when
Joe Biden would have run and we know as
I mentioned about his family situation
which undoubtedly was a factor in him
not running I did receive one email from
a viewer saying David I'm already
reading about people discussing whether
it's a good idea for Joe Biden to run
these people seem kin
that were even going to have another
presidential election I believe we will
have another presidential election I'm
gonna be on record Pat as saying that
now it may be an even more bogus
presidential election than we've had
before but I think we will at least on
paper have an election in 2020 I think
the Union will survive these next four
years